I'm one of those people that when I'm
walking I'm like scrolling through my
phone book all the time that's like my
my habit and I'm just like looking and
if I make it to the D's then the next
time I try to remember that it was I
left on D and the next time I'll just
scroll from d and I'll just find someone
I'll be like oh I haven't talked to that
person a while I wonder what would be
interesting to send them like say hi how
you doing or maybe there's something
that's one element of it to the point
that I've even created like subgroups of
my address book that are like one of
them is called Walking calls and they're
like people that if I'm going on a walk
I feel like I could just randomly call
them so I'll go to that group um so
that's one is just like using my free
kind of mindless time to try to find
people that I want to stay in touch with
and just forcibly staying in
touch